podríais decirme qué haríais con 250
millones de dólares billones en
españoles estoy seguro de que os vienen
un montón de caprichos a la cabeza
efectivamente es una cantidad tan grande
de dinero que vamos hay años que ni
siquiera bill gates los ganas pero si
ahora os digo que esos 250 billones de
dólares son dólares de zimbabue la cosa
cambia y mucho
por 250 millones de dólares de zimbabue
en 2015 te daban estad atentos 1 dólar
estadounidense tal cual como lo oís lo
cierto es que zimbabue es como venezuela
pero a escala nacho vidal jana es el
país del mundo que ha sufrido la
inflación más salvaje de la historia
desde más o menos el año 2000 los
precios subían cada año de forma
disparatada ya en el año 2008 una barra
de pan valía ojo al dato 10.000 dólares
zimbabuenses
y os preguntaréis cómo ha pasado esto
pues es muy sencillo un día le llego
robert mugabe a su ministro de finanzas
y dijo oye mira a ver cómo te las
arreglas porque necesitamos más dinero y
que hizo el bueno del ministro pues lo
mismo que haría el padre de neymar si le
dejarán darle a la máquina de imprimir
billetes como si no hubiera mañana
conclusión zimbabue ha tenido que
renunciar a su propia moneda y ha visto
como las monedas extranjeras
especialmente el dólar estadounidense
dominaban su economía pero qué está
pasando ahora en zimbabue en estas
últimas semanas de 2017 el país está
siendo noticia porque ha llegado el
final de robert mugabe
un golpe de estado donde las fuerzas
armadas han acabado con una dictadura de
37 años y mis queridos amigos de visual
política hay que reconocer una cosa ni
los golpes de estado son ya lo que eran
te puedes decir que esto ya ha sido algo
así como un golpe de estado online
especialmente cuando leemos noticias
como esta
robert mugabe recibirá una indemnización
de 10 millones de dólares e inmunidad
para su familia lo cierto es que este
dictador se ha visto envuelto en una
trama propia de telenovela mugabe con 93
años quería morir en el poder y que su
esposa grace de 52 años heredará la
presidencia del país cosas así solamente
suceden en argentina corea del norte o
el frente nacional en francia y como os
podéis imaginar había muchísima gente
que no estaba de acuerdo así que ante
cualquier gesto de oposición a estos
planes el clan mugabe mostraba al
disidente de turno el camino del
aeropuerto de hararé
y esto fue precisamente lo que pasó
cuando a principios de noviembre
enviaron al exilio al vicepresidente
emmerson mnangagwa la reacción del
ejército no se hizo esperar y el
resultado ya lo sabéis pero ahora son
muchas las incógnitas que se ciernen
sobre zimbabue smng agua
el nuevo mugabe podrá resucitar la
economía de zimbabue hoy vamos a
responder a estas preguntas pero antes
vamos a ver un poco de historia
efecto 2000 efectivamente la economía de
zimbabue es un auténtico desastre y
estaréis pensando dictadura y áfrica
suena como el cóctel perfecto para tener
corrupción y pobreza pues tenéis razón
pero solamente en parte hubo una época
en la que esto no era así
de hecho zimbabue era conocida como la
joya de áfrica es más sus tierras
fértiles habían convertido en el granero
del continente y os preguntaréis qué
pasó entonces para que un país con
tantísimos recursos agrícolas con
recursos naturales y con minas de oro y
otros metales haya pasado a ser un país
en la más absoluta ruina
la respuesta tiene nombre y apellidos
robert mugabe 37 años hace de la
independencia de zimbabue y 37 años ha
estado mugabe en el poder la
descolonización de la llamada rhodesia
del sur que era una colonia británica
provocó una guerra civil durante 15 años
de un lado el gobierno de la minoría
blanca que suponía un 5 por ciento de la
población
enfrentados además a sus superiores del
reino unido- porque habían proclamado
unilateralmente la independencia y no
habían tenido el reconocimiento
internacional del otro lado las fuerzas
guerrilleras comandadas por robert
mugabe líder de una ideología que
combinaba el nacionalismo
antiimperialista con el comunismo
por aquel entonces margaret thatcher era
la primera ministra del reino unido- y
ya sé lo que estaréis pensando guerra
fría más un gobierno comunista más
margaret thatcher no combinan
precisamente bien verdad pues os
equivocáis por aquel entonces el reino
unido- tenía como prioridad dejar que
sus antiguas colonias se convirtieran en
democracias así que la propia margaret
thatcher recién llegada a downing
street- firmó un acuerdo de paz con
zimbabwe y organizó unas elecciones en
el país elecciones que fueron todos los
libres que pueden ser cuando acabas de
salir de una guerra civil y tienes a
guerrilleros por todo el país y quien
creéis que ganó estos comicios
efectivamente
robert mugabe
y os preguntaréis tiene credibilidad su
victoria pues todo indica a que sí
veréis dentro de la población negra de
zimbabue que es la inmensa mayoría
frente al 5% que había de blancos pero
dominan dos grupos étnicos por un lado
tenemos a los zona que representan un
80% de la población y por el otro
quedamos con este nombre los mata vélez
que son solamente un 10%
pues bien robert mugabe es de la etnia
de los zona y por eso a nadie le extrañó
su amplia victoria en las urnas con más
de un 60% de los votos así que en 1980
reino unido concedió entonces la
independencia a rhodes ya que pasó a
llamarse zimbabue y así es como mugabe
comenzó a manejar este joven país a su
antojo en sólo siete años consiguió
absorber todos los poderes políticos en
torno a su figura
pero esperad un momento porque hay que
reconocer que a nivel económico la cosa
funcionaba al menos en los primeros años
jugable respeto los derechos de
propiedad es sobre la tierra por lo que
el sector primario siguió tirando de la
economía sin embargo y al más puro
estilo de los políticos venezolanos muy
graves se gastó todo el dinero que tenía
ahorrado el anterior gobierno colonial
por supuesto que aunque a largo plazo
sea bastante discutible y los números no
terminen de salir hay que reconocerle un
logro a robert mugabe zimbabue logró
rápidamente la mayor tasa de
alfabetización del continente con
niveles próximos al 90 por ciento
y qué es lo siguiente que hace un
dictador pues cargarse a la oposición lo
cierto es que para eso mugabe no reparó
en gastos envió a la quinta brigada del
ejército a corea del norte para que
aprendieran de sus métodos de opresión
política y cuando a la quinta brigada
regresó a zimbabue les dijo y dónde
están los mata vélez y a rashad con todo
y así es como en los años 80 mugabe
ejecutó el llamado gurú cajón de
q cura jundi significa en el idioma sana
la lluvia que limpia la paja antes de
las lluvias de primavera
esta operación consistía en una salvaje
limpieza étnica un genocidio en toda
regla en el que más de 20.000 personas
de la etnia de los mata vélez fueron
asesinadas y así es como mugabe logró
mantenerse sin apenas oposición política
hasta el año 2000
y en ese año mugabe decidió poner en
marcha una reforma agraria
revolucionaria nada volvió a hacer como
era y todo cambió a peor
mugabe decidió que no podía ser que las
mejores tierras fueran propiedad de la
minoría blanca así que se las arrebató
por la fuerza
y quien recibió buena parte de esas
tierras efectivamente los ministros y
aliados políticos de mugabe que no
tenían ni idea ni recursos para trabajar
la tierra los resultados fueron tan
revolucionarios como la reforma la
producción agraria cayó en picado
mientras la hiperinflación de la que ya
os he hablado disparaba los precios
desde entonces
zimbabue vive un auténtico apocalipsis
económico
la hora del cocodrilo dicen que los
cocodrilos esperan pacientemente bajo el
agua asomando solo los ojos y las fosas
nasales hasta que una victima incauta se
descuide y entonces atacan ferozmente
con sus mandíbulas no amigos de visual
político no queremos ser el nuevo
national geographic sino simplemente
explicaros por qué el nuevo presidente
de zimbabue
emmerson mnangagwa es conocido como el
cocodrilo
managua fue uno más de los líderes de la
guerrilla de mugabe y ha sido ministro
de zimbabue desde 1980 así que ha estado
toda la vida a la sombra del dictador
agazapado como un cocodrilo esperando su
momento y ese momento ha llegado sus
primeros pasos han sido poco arriesgados
tal y como muestran noticias como esta
el gabinete del líder de zimbabwe se
apoya en los militares y en el partido
gobernante por eso junto a estas medidas
tan conservadoras ha dado otros pasos un
poquito más arriesgados como éste
el gobierno enmienda la ley de
indigenización la ley de indigenización
es otra medida económica de esas que son
100% mugabe style esta consistió en que
las empresas de cierto tamaño no podían
ser propiedad de los blancos y eso
explica cómo os podéis imaginar que la
gente blanca haya emigrado y ya sean
menos de un 1% de la población pero
rechazar hacer negocios con alguien
basándote únicamente en su raza no
parece la mejor manera de atraer la
inversión internacional y zimbabue
necesita dinero del extranjero
pero esperad un momento porque manga
guau podría no ser la persona más
adecuada para dirigir los designios del
país en un país como zimbabwe encontrar
puntos negros en el historial de alguien
tan próximo a mugabe es pan comido
qué hacía malanga agua en los años 80
pues era el ministro de seguridad
nacional por lo que a la fuerza algo
tuvo que ver con el cura holding como os
podéis imaginar ser un genocida no
parece la mejor carta de presentación
para empezar a dirigir un país y os
preguntaréis acaso no hay nadie que haga
una oposición firme a este régimen pues
lo cierto es que si tal cual como lo es
en el año 2008 el dictador vio como otro
partido recibía más apoyo
la crisis política fue enorme por un
lado mugabe no podía atacar a un
opositor con tantísimo capital político
y apoyo social por el otro como buen
dictador no podía reconocerle la
victoria así que mugabe optó por una
decisión salomónica siguió ostentando la
presidencia de la república y cedió a
este líder opositor que se llamaba
morgan tsvangirai los poderes de primer
ministro pero esperad un momento porque
esta confesión no fue más que un
espejismo y durante cuatro años este
líder opositor apenas tuvo margen de
actuación si el país pudo crecer
ligeramente especialmente cuando
adaptaron el dólar estadounidense como
moneda
por lo demás los cambios fueron mínimos
y zimbabue continuó dando noticias al
mundo como esta
casa de empleo de zimbabwe en el 90% por
eso van kirk ay no parece ya una
alternativa al régimen así que con el
anuncio de elecciones para el próximo
año todo indica que el camino está
despejado para el cocodrilo el ejército
va a tutelar los próximos tiempos de
zimbabue con una ventaja respecto a
mugabe hacerlo peor en economía es
imposible
así que ahora la pregunta es os parece
que managua será capaz de hacer que
zimbabue vuelva a ser la joya de áfrica
o simplemente se limitará a ocupar el
trono de mugabe
podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios
mientras tanto si queréis conocer la
historia de otro país africano en este
vídeo os hablamos de egipto haced clic
aquí para verlo y no olvidéis que
sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las semanas
así que suscribiros al canal para no
perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones si os han gustado este
vídeo dadle a like y nos vemos en el
próximo un abrazo y hasta pronto